so you guys probably saw at least the
images perhaps the video of the 21
Coptic Christians that they beheaded on
the beach it was I think in Libya yeah
in Libya yeah it was pretty awful so I
don't want to get too into the minutiae
of that but what I think is interesting
about this is this debate that we're
starting to have a little bit about the
propaganda should we be showing these
videos should we be talking about them
are we just eating in their propaganda
are we making them more it's more easily
here's some of the images you can see
right here I mean they just beheaded 21
of these people at the same time and
then there were images of bloody water
it was pretty terrible but basically you
know are we aiding in their propaganda
when we talk about this stuff are we
somehow strengthening them we've talked
about it a little bit before yes yes
even what we're doing right now is
strengthening its true Spicer Tinley
what Fox News did you know at least if
we're commenting on it we're not
forwarding their propaganda in a sense
but with Fox News do when they showed
that unedited 22 minute video that they
put out that you are now providing a
platform for their propaganda yeah you
are you're not talking about this when
you're talking with the Jordanian side
let the Jordan pop but this is a but but
you know when Chris Matthews goes on
MSNBC and he's like oh my god what are
we gonna do we got to come together and
fight this people that's exactly what
Isis wants us to do they want us to
overreach they this goodness is that not
our problem this is a thousands of year
old problem between Sunnis and Shias
that we shouldn't be getting in the
middle of and we can't bomb our way out
of this yeah should we feel a little
guilty because we are the ones as you
alluded to in the last segment that
started the Iraq the wrong Iraq war and
thus left this guy thank you I think
that I don't think it's easy and I think
if there's a way to to get these but
there's an opportunity always an
opportunity when there's guys this crazy
because by the way I watched that video
I found it I watched it a couple things
happen when I watched it because I
wanted to see I don't know I mama I was
journalist I'd been if I'd been working
of course I would have seen it and I
thought I should see it yeah it's
incredibly hard to watch i-i've I'm
incredibly struck by the by the
composure of the victims in this so I
don't know what's happening there cuz
you there are and it's made mm-hmm so
but that said it is it depresses you it
is it can ruin your in
tired a to watch one of these videos I
don't know that we're furthering their
propaganda because one thing that is
happening is that as these guys keep
doing things like this they're making
enemies of our enemies yeah and and in
that is an opportunity that maybe
there's some evidence as you mentioned
with the arming the Syrian was that
missus segment or the last second a lot
of it we are willing to have Syrian
anti-assad rebels orchestrate our
airstrikes the this has opened up
opportunities with Iran that this is so
the the Muslim world even some jihadists
are together in that hey-hey-hey-hey
maybe stop cutting people's heads off
maybe stop executing women in the street
that was al Qaeda that video and and
that made Isis angry so there are
opportunities here I don't know what you
shouldn't air their whole video I get
that but I don't know that talking about
it is is is the wrong thing to do they
want us oh come they want the end times
when they want they are there they are
saying hey come get us
come put American boots on the gas they
want it they do you see that distinction
though between talking about it and
showing the stuff because that's okay
right so there was the video of the
woman being shot that they literally
just shot another elderly woman it was
resear and all these people were
cheering above about now I tweeted the
link because to me it's like we need to
understand some of this like if this was
a world war two I think if people had
maybe see more images of concentration
capture saying maybe we would have done
more now again I'm not saying we should
do anything I was against the Iraq war a
year ago but to me seeing it doesn't
necessarily mean we have to do something
but we can at least have a debate about
it which I don't think we really do know
I think it's it's good in a sense if we
talk about it in the right way meaning
we don't let these videos make us
thirsty for blood yeah don't let those
videos make us one ramp up our war and
by the way that woman who got shot in
the street in Syria she was talking loud
on a cell phone in an elevator I mean I
mean at some point you have to draw a
line and I'm glad that finally they are
in Syria yeah how powerful do you think
Isis really is because that's the other
part related to the propaganda thing
yeah we see
these horrible things I didn't watch the
21 people get beheaded but you we see
all this stuff and then part of me is
like is to your point like I don't want
to overstate how much power they
actually have they don't have an Air
Force you know what I mean like we've
killed 6,000 of them we were told in the
beginning there was 20 to 50,000 of them
killing 6,000 if there's 20,000 you made
a big difference so I'm I'm for look I
would be for finishing them off quickly
if I thought that that would work yeah
you know we just know that in that we're
not we don't seem capable of that we
don't seem capable is's in Grenada we
can't go in spend 72 hours there and
leave and high-five each other and say
look Reagan just won a war we tell you
something else that happen that I meant
to mention very quickly when I looked at
that video I was really worried about
looking up that video and I thought
people were gonna know I looked I
thought the same exact that was the
first time that I thought the people the
NSA is that's a crazy thing to think
about that that the government is
watching me look at this video and will
they think that I'm that I like this
video that I want and I thought so I
should just stop I know but I mean I
don't think anybody's really looking but
it was chilling it was chilling it
affected I'm in my own office in my home
afraid of what I'm looking up on the
computer that was a weird thing to feel
well to that point we did a story last
week at something like 63 percent of
reporters in the United States think
that the government spying on them so
that's a big that's a pretty high number
it's almost half you might be right